-Oh, it's Jimmy Fallon.
♪♪ It's Jimmy Fallon ♪♪
♪♪ Unh ♪♪
♪♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Fallon, oh
What?!
♪♪ It's Jimmy Fallon ♪♪
-Aw, come on!
♪♪ Huh? ♪♪
♪♪ Say who? ♪♪
♪♪ Say what? ♪♪
That was --
I'm doing a little David Spade
♪♪ And, oh, and, oh ♪♪
[ Both laugh ]
How you doing, bud?
-You know what's so crazy?
I'm doing good.
It's so nuts, because, uh...
the other night, after
"Saturday Night Live" was on -
right after "SNL,"
they went straight to an "SNL"
from like early '90s.
And my kids were watching,
right?
And so, like, the "SNL" cast
of the early '90s,
to them, is like --
it's like The Three Stooge
and Charlie Chaplin, right
They just don't even, like -
I think they're like,
"Wait.
Isn't that a guy from 'Shrek'?
Like, they don't really --
They can't make --
They can't bridge the gap,
right?
-Yeah.
-And I was sitting there,
and I was thinking, like,
back in the day,
when we first met, like,
that was a long, long time ago
Right?
And you look at that cast
from then and think, like,
it's the [bleep] Mount Rushmor
of [bleep] popular culture
And I'm like -- I'm trying
to explain to my kids, like,
"No, see, that -- that guy right
there, that was 'Tommy Boy.'
That's [bleep] 'Tommy Boy.'"
I'm like, "That guy right there,
that's the voice
from 'The Simpsons.'"
It's insane.
-I mean, Phil Hartman --
everyone -- Jan Hooks,
Victoria Jackson...
Like, that season,
with Mike Myers and Dana?
-It's insane.
Like, think about those days
It's so bananas.
-Dude, and, like, Smigel
would, like, write like
10 sketches a week
to try to get one on.
10 a week he would write.
It's like
they were all machines.
-It's just like person
after person after person.
Julia Sweeney, like,
you start --
you see all these --
Oh, dude.
I mean, everybody was so good.
-I looked forward
to every single person.
We just had Dana and Mike on
'cause they were doing
the Super Bowl commercial,
and it was like -- and jus
to watch those dynamics...
'Cause Dana is so, like,
"Da be da ba, ba de bo,"
and he's doing these bits,
and Mike is just going like,
"Yeah."
-[ Laughs ]
-That's what made it.
But it's like, "Wow!"
And Mike brought --
He was the new kid
and brought in Dieter.
Do you remember Dieter?
"Sprockets"?
He did "Sprockets,"
he did "Wayne's World."
And do you remember
"Lothar of the Hill People"?
Oh, my God, I remember that.
-Dude, I don't remember what i
was about, but it was great.
Like, Lothar...
-That's the one movie
that Lorne didn't make.
Like, why wasn't...
-The Lothar script is probably
somewhere out there.
-Come on.
It's floating around out -
Let's do it!
-Let's make
"Lothar of the Hill People."
Let's call Mike tomorrow
and be like,
"Let's just do it, man."
And get everyone we know to just
be one of the Hill People.
And make, like,
a new Monty Python.
Why not?
This has to be a script.
-It's moments like these
that change history.
You realize that, Jimmy Fallon
This is how it works.